Pero no quiero que me malinterpreten,
entiendo totalmente la importancia del ritual,
sobre todo cuando se trata de la gente que amamos.
Pero tenemos que poder crear y practicar este ritual
sin dañar el ambiente,
por lo que necesitamos nuevas opciones.
Así que volvamos a la idea de protección, saneamiento y embellecimiento.
Empezaremos con un cadáver.
La industria funeraria protegerá su cadáver
ofreciendo vender a su familia un ataúd de madera dura o metal
con un sellador de caucho.
En el cementerio, el día del entierro, ese ataúd será bajado
a una gran bóveda de hormigón o metal.
Estamos desperdiciando estos recursos - hormigón, metal, maderas duras -
ocultándolos en vastas fortalezas subterráneas.
Cuando uno elige el entierro en el cementerio,
el cadáver no llega a ninguna parte en la tierra que lo rodea.
Alimento para gusanos,
no serán.
Luego, la industria desinfectará el cuerpo mediante embalsamamiento:
la preservación química de los muertos.
Este procedimiento drena la sangre
y la sustituye por un formaldehído cancerígeno, tóxico.
Dicen que lo hacen por la salud pública
porque el cadáver puede ser peligroso,
pero los médicos de esta sala les dirán
que esto solo sería así
si la persona hubiera muerto de alguna enfermedad infecciosa, como el Ébola.
Incluso la descomposición humana que, seamos honestos,
es un algo apestoso y desagradable,
es perfectamente segura.
Las bacterias que causan enfermedad no son las mismas bacterias
que causan descomposición.
Por último, la industria embellecerá el cadáver.
Dirá que el cadáver natural de tu madre o de tu padre
no es bueno tal como es.
Le pondrá maquillaje.
Le pondrá un traje.
Le inyectará tintes para que la persona parezca un poco más viva...
solo descansa.
El embalsamamiento es un truco
que da la ilusión de que la muerte y la decadencia no son el fin natural
de la vida orgánica en el planeta.
Si este sistema de embellecimiento, saneamiento y protección
no les gusta,
no están solos.
Hay toda una serie de gente
- directores de funerarias, diseñadores, ambientalistas -
que tratan de llegar a una manera de morir más ecológica.
Para estas personas, la muerte no es necesariamente
un tema de maquillaje y un traje azul impecable.
No hay duda,
nuestros actuales métodos de muerte no son particularmente sostenibles,
el desperdicio de recursos y nuestra confianza en los productos químicos.
Incluso la cremación,
que generalmente se considera la opción ecológica,
usa, por cada cremación,
el equivalente en gas natural de un viaje en auto de 800 km.
Entonces, ¿hacia dónde vamos?
El verano pasado, estaba en las montañas de Carolina del Norte,
transportando baldes de astillas de madera bajo el sol estival.
Estuve en Western Carolina University en su "granja de cuerpos",
más exactamente llamada "instalación de descomposición humana".
Se traen aquí los cuerpos donados a la ciencia
y se estudia su decadencia en beneficio del futuro de la medicina forense.
En este día en particular,
había 12 cuerpos dispuestos en diversas etapas de descomposición.
Algunos eran esqueletos,
uno tenía un pijama púrpura,
uno aún tenía vello facial rubio visible.
El aspecto forense es realmente fascinante,
pero no era esa la razón por la que estaba allí.
Estaba allí porque una colega llamada Katrina Spade
intenta crear un sistema, no para cremar muertos,
sino para el compostaje de muertos.
Denomina "Recomposición" al sistema,
y lo hemos hecho con ganado y otros animales durante años.
Ella imagina una instalación
donde la familia podría ir a poner a su muerto amado
en una mezcla rica en nutrientes que, de cuatro a seis semanas,
reduciría los huesos del cuerpo y todo... a tierra.
En esas cuatro a seis semanas,
sus moléculas se convierten en otras moléculas;
literalmente se transforman.
¿Cómo encajaría esto con el deseo muy reciente
que muchas personas parecen tener
de ser enterrados bajo un árbol,
o convertirse en árbol al morir?
En una cremación tradicional, las cenizas que quedan
- fragmentos óseos inorgánicos -
forman una capa gruesa y calcárea
que, a menos que se distribuya en el suelo de manera adecuada,
puede dañar o matar al árbol.
Pero si se recompone, si uno vuelve a la tierra,
puede nutrir al árbol,
y volverse el colaborador post mortem que siempre quiso ser...
que uno merece ser.
Esa es una opción para el futuro de la cremación.
Pero ¿y el futuro de los cementerios?
Hay mucha gente que piensa que ya no deberíamos tener cementerios
porque nos estamos quedando sin tierra.
Pero, ¿qué pasa si lo reenmarcamos,
y vemos al cadáver no como el enemigo de la tierra,
sino como su potencial salvador?
Estoy hablando de entierros de conservación,
donde un fideicomiso compra grandes extensiones de tierra.
La belleza de esto es que una vez que uno pone cadáveres en esa tierra,
no puede tocarse, no se puede construir allí,
de ahí el término "enterramiento de conservación".
Es el equivalente de encadenarse a un árbol post mortem...
"¡Diablos, no, no iré!
No, de verdad... no puedo. me estoy descomponiendo por aquí".
(Risas)
El dinero que la familia da al cementerio
volvería a la protección y a la gestión de la tierra.
No hay lápidas ni tumbas en el sentido típico.
Las tumbas están dispersas por la propiedad
bajo montículos elegantes,
marcados solo por una roca o un pequeño disco de metal,
o a veces ubicables solo por GPS.
No hay embalsamamiento,
ni ataúdes de metal, pesados.
Mi funeraria vende algunos ataúdes
de sauce tejido y bambú.
Pero honestamente, la mayoría de las familias elige un sudario simple.
No tiene las grandes bóvedas que requieren la mayoría de los cementerios
porque les facilita ser parte del paisaje.
Las familias pueden venir aquí; pueden disfrutar la naturaleza;
incluso pueden plantar un árbol o un arbusto,
aunque solo se permiten plantas nativas.
Los muertos se integran a la perfección con el paisaje.
Hay esperanza en los cementerios de conservación.
Ofrecen espacio verde dedicado en zonas urbanas y rurales.
Ofrecen la oportunidad de reintroducir flora y fauna nativas a una región.
Ofrecen senderos públicos,
lugares para práctica espiritual,
lugares para clases y eventos,
lugares donde confluyen el duelo y la naturaleza.
Más importante, nos ofrecen, una vez más,
una oportunidad de descomponernos en un agujero en la tierra.
La tierra,
les diré,
nos ha echado de menos.
Pienso que mucha gente
está empezando a darse cuenta
de que la industria funeraria actual no los satisface.
Para muchos de nosotros,
que nos desinfecten y embellezcan no nos refleja.
No refleja lo que defendimos durante nuestras vidas.
¿El cambio en la forma de enterrar los muertos resolverá el cambio climático?
No.
Pero hará movimientos audaces
en nuestras formas de vernos como ciudadanos de este planeta.
Si podemos morir de una manera más humilde y autoconsciente,
creo que tenemos una oportunidad.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)